good sorry I'm a little bighorn that's
right you've been busy okay good yep bad
economy time so
so just just make it look pretty I got a
party to go to
the song
thought you [ __ ]
how long has it been buddy
you
scars
sure
strong
was for you
have to give up
I got a taco
can you hear me how are ya how's it
going yeah working just work it right in
a way you gotta stick it up man you got
two seconds
Oh
oh man what you been up to you're
looking good back there yeah whatever
i'm just trying to define it
by the hill music but they kind of
picked out a little bit right and you're
not suffering much you know it's worse
worse really people are running out of
money their cash reserves are and
unfortunately you know my clientele is
just you know pretty much on the
industry no I'm breaking for a really
bad summer how's the dog he's good you
should bring him to work so I can oh my
god never he's crazy he's a
three-year-old lavador that's shampoo
toughen up there boy like what's going
on here are you talking about it's a
brand new day the lights out I'm gonna
get high get you want a smoke hold on
sleep you know you're like it you're
like I haven't seen you in a while and
it it's like I'm it's like I'm seeing
someone totally good I like that you're
in good shape break it out love this
[ __ ] movie man
so what the hell what's going on with
you man so sad she's fully answer my
questions she's still around it's who's
still around Sarah will not be alone
Sarah was never really are you doing
this you're [ __ ] wasting your life
away you're not only insulting everybody
around you and your talent and your and
your stage presence and everything you
have gone for you but it's just the
waist we were like this we were like
this and then and then at some point you
went off like this and I stick and I
stayed the course and I've stayed the
course for seven years as well
at one point I really admired you I
really I really thought that you had
potential out here and you're funny and
you charismatic and when I met you you
were a different person and now look at
you you got a shirt that says big
mistake on it you think you're giving
back to the world are you giving back to
the world by smoking pot yes yeah the
world is there me are you proud of
yourself are you proud of what you've
become
I'm ha
I'm out of here honestly I'm done
because I literally don't think anything
has an effect on you anymore I think
that's fried referring so much that you
don't even understand so I'm going I'm
leaving oh no I'm done well no I've done
it what whoa come on white I'm done yeah
yeah yeah just hang out why
thanks a good man thanks for yeah yeah
man they're they're good man again
another agents and I got a manager and
yeah how they doing anything for you
yeah yeah they are I mean yeah I mean
nobody's perfect it's not like I'm worth
repeating remorse or anything but yeah
man I mean they're doing stuff it's got
60 say no man no I'm just trying to make
it like just like everyone else man I
possibly could you don't end up like
that one of these sons but Stan you
don't want oh so y'all gonna cook
themselves you want to get your ass back
in here uh I'm sorry hold on one second
man no I'm just give me five minutes
please I'm just I rarely ever get from
do I just just I did I just all just
want to say goodbye just for one second
I mean I barely ever get friends two
minutes he's just sorry you I'd say you
know it's not time to be socializing
with you haven't even take a break yet
get your ass in here all right are you
okay
welcome to my world my friend welcome to
my world
I heard the shortest joke in the world
today want to hear it sure an Irishman
walks past a bar I like that one
I don't know what to do I really don't
know
I just want the best for you and I just
want you to read find that passion you
had d know how long has been since I've
been on that stage Vicky yourself out
you were on stage you're funny you know
you walk on stage and people start
laughing only if they load you bed when
you get on the stage you get the crowd
with you like boom there by just can't
do it anymore why oh there's got to be a
reason that you lost this dry it can't
just be the drugs it's something else
and I that's for you to figure out it
just know that it goes deeper life stand
difficult
you're the only person I told us you
know that you've been a out of your 15
years and nothing's happening you're
working at a [ __ ] taco stand with the
guy with a bow tie I mean with the [ __ ]
yeah I guess I look back at it sometimes
I don't know what the hell I'm doing but
I just I can't quit you know I think
about it a lot man
he said man we've been over and over
with the family and I don't I just I did
the last time you saw everything my
family it's been like management like
man I don't even remember like two and a
half years yeah I'm like three years ago
my grandparents died
my my parents told me you know if you
don't come back for their funeral then
you don't need to come back at all I
guess you know it's like crap like that
man that I just don't know if they want
me back man
you know I guess that's how I think
about I don't know if they want me back
why wouldn't they want you better I
guess it just spent years and years
convincing them that they were there was
stupid for not supporting me out here
and I not letting me do my do my thing
and so I feel like if I go back now alls
I'm going to here for the rest of my
life as I told you so and I'm just going
to have that like voice that like nas at
you every freaking moment of your life
that's that's that voice man that voice
it just doesn't let me quit
preciate the can see me back you to
appreciate its own
you
Travis Matt on you again I know it's
after hours that called you earlier I
was asking about the Bruckheimer
breakdown
it's a given that you gotta call me back
and you gotta let me know if I can get
in there things don't really go away
they just eat all
you